[Music]
oh my
gosh well I have to start with this
happy birthday I know we got the skirt
memo it's your birthday today yes so
what do you do on your birthday do you
do you go all out do you have big plans
I'm kind of a boring lady turns out I'm
a boring lady and today you know the
movie coming out is this is the best
person that's kind of the great gift
could have ever been yes totally I mean
this you were already incredible before
but this is literally I feel like
waitress and just just the getting to
know you more as an artist and the scope
of your talent like has blown up your
career in such a different kind of way
like it really is a blessing to have
people like you always had that talent
but to be able to show people like
that's a big gift and it's such a
blessing for a birthday present yeah and
now it's and now it's a movie they're
doing the so it's basically they took
what what it is on stage and then made
it a movie right yes so when we opened
after the after Broadway was closed in
the during the pandemic heard of it
pandemic heard yeah y the world is going
great um yeah so after we um closed we
got the opportunity to reopen and so
when we did it became like a very
important um intention for us to get to
you know have this captured and so it
was kind of an All-Star cast and we we
got back on stage and we took four days
and we shot some with an audience and
some that were just set up so we got to
bring the cameras really close to the
action on stage and um yeah it's very
handmade we've been working really
really hard on this I love that though
the is the best cuz you really get in
there especially if you take that time
to take those extra days to really get
close-ups on people and really see the
emotion it's like seeing it in a
different way it's when they theater
you're sort of spitting to get to the
back but in this you sort of get into
the action in a in a different way and
it it came out so beautiful I'm super
proud so I'm super proud of you that's
so cool man you're just so gifted and
just for everybody that can't get to
Broadway I know but just CU people can't
always get here to see a show so to give
them that opportunity to be a part of
the ride cuz it's such a huge successful
hit and it touches so many people I know
I covered that song and girl I'm telling
you what oh if you think I haven't
watched using that song 3,000 times if
you think that I literally I was like I
had to not I closed my eyes for the
entire thing cuz I hadn't seen we and so
I was like I really didn't know what I
was walking into and that song is so
beautiful thank you oh my God she is to
be mine if you know what I'm talking
like it's like the most amazing
song I literally like I got through it
once and I was proud to get through it
without just completely breaking down
because I'm an emotional nutcase but
yeah it's get to know me my cross to
bear yeah it's like whatever I'm with
you I'm with
[Music]
[Applause]
you thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home
m